ganz nach im neuen blog aus und damit
direkt herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen episode luca erzählt euch schon
seinen träumen ich habe mich geträumt
ich werde in einer eisfabrik
eingeschoben
sprachen lernen ich hab geträumt ich
werde der eisfabrik eingesperrt gewesen
und dann bin ich da drin erfroren
ich bin ich einfach eingeschlafen war
sollen schlimmer totem ich aufgewacht
war schweißgebadet weiß man kann man
übrigens noch immer keine teller in
meiner wohnung deshalb ich meinen
bestellten reichstag aus dem topf fest
highlife ich habe mir für meine lampe im
schlafzimmer der glühbirne bestellt und
jetzt haben die heute an ich habe die
ausgepackt und es sieht so aus
perfekt dass das wird eine dunkle nacht
mal wieder als mit einem kumpel in
sonnefeld metro einkaufen davon
eigentlich noch rein wenn man irgendwie
ein krasser gastronom ist und ein
anderer hat aber ich kann mich
eigentlich bin
27 minuten zu spät oder dreiviertel
stunde auch mal gefunden
ja ich bin da wie sind wir frei gekommen
hier in den laden in den laden betraten
hier video graf wir machen ganz
klassischen risikograd machen wir ja
auch hier gerade ich habe keller
gefunden brauchte ich wohne seit mehr
als einer woche jetzt in hamburg hat man
keine dass intel also ich hab jetzt
quasi nutella-hersteller neue teller
nutella zwar weil man wird zwar lustig
weil alles vom fernseher über mahlers
und auch kleidung irgendwo gibt es
wahrscheinlich noch waffen plüsch decken
ich dir los für teller was kaufe ich
alles außer teller ist es einfach so ein
krasses einkaufen hier guckt euch das an
das ist der raumstation
[Musik]
welcher mensch kauft sich bitte fertig
rührei pro minute und das fertiggerichte
dort wahrscheinlich 5 also ist es
richtig mit den masken aber zum film als
er sie gar nicht meine mimik was
vielleicht ob er seinen fünf kilo
tomaten hat die ganze palette am besten
direkt ein ja wenn wir noch länger
bleiben brauchen wir einen dritten wagen
alles ein
jetzt bin ich wieder metro und ich habe
alles außer meine 1000 einmal in die
trierer handschuhe in blau auch geil
haben sie hier perfekt broich dann auch
noch 1000 liter mit einer firma nach
perfekt ja ich brauchte auch noch 300
mal dem playboy ja aber entspannt
einkaufen aber der neue mega macht spaß
[Musik]
ratet mal jetzt unten in den kommentaren
wie teuer der komplette einkauf fünf
sekunden zeit
43 21
649 euro ich muss dazu sagen das ist
erstmal ein jahreseinkommen der reicht
jetzt ein paar tage ja das ist dann das
nächste problem 17 jahre später wir
haben tetris durchgespielt der
kofferraum vorne ist wirklich komplett
voll und auf jede karte der beifahrer
sitzen es voll hier ist alles gefordert
alles selbstverständlich gesichert ich
bedanke mich madame ich fahr nach hause
läuft die noch ich von dir dass
natürlich die kabine geführt hatte mit
gepackt ist jetzt gelte es die antarktis
wisst ihr was mir gerade aufhält
ich habe glaube ich mehr einbauschränke
als baby mein letzter blogs avantgarde
die trends gekommen und zwar auf platz
sieben und er hat gerade 42.000 zu 470
bewertungen und ich sage euch es geht
mindestens auf 5006 hoch weil in den
trends nur komische leute unterwegs sind
[Musik]
das gut ist wenn man nur einmal auspackt
kann es einfach direkt reinschmeißen
weil es ja und dann kann man live acts
mit lukas schaltet jetzt besser ab ich
habe übrigens zwei arten von freunden
die einen haben wir zu meiner neuen
wohnung und zum einzug eine
tomatenpflanze geschenkt mega lieb die
anderen haben wir drei kondome geschenkt
auch mega lied ich habe mir übrigens
raumduft bestellten habe einfach eine
karte bei und in der karte steht einfach
drin lieber luca viel spaß mit einem
bescheuert überteuerten raumduft liebe
grüße der luca freundlich von denen
dieser schritt habe ich 250 gekostet das
wäre ich werde joggen und duschen und
ich wollte mich dann rasieren in der
dusche und hatte so muskelkater dass ich
auf dem boden geklappt bin immer das
tolle war ganz kurz auf den meist
geschriebenen kommentar und an meinem
comeback blog eingehen und zwar luca
machst du ne vum tour war er nicht da
ist keine linke von meiner wohnung in
köln gemacht und will das auch für meine
hamburger wohnung hier vorerst nicht
machen ich finde man sieht schon relativ
viel in den blogs allerdings wird zeit
den rahmen sprengen so ich wohne hier
auf 20.000 quadratmetern das video wird
dann sieben stock hat die fresse du
laden also um die frage zu beantworten
vielleicht irgendwann mal vorerst aber
nicht weil es auch noch nicht alles
fertig ständiger wandel hier der wohnung
und jetzt braucht ihr das auch nicht
mehr in die kommentare schreiben im ok
fünf minuten kommt ein kumpel von mir
und wir wollten unbedingt heute
lange folge haben machen wir das die
ganze zeit wollten erst in 5 minuten
ich muss kranken das zweite finale
finale 3 finale nummer vier
der kardinal 56
ich weiß ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht
wie das alles ist was eigentlich nur
vorteile dieses 10 11
[Musik]
34 ja das kommt das letzte finale
niklas bildschirme draußen die schule
die krone ich will mich als online was
bestellen und ihnen die spinnt ihr kennt
das ja hier wahrscheinlich selbe weise
dazu können roboter bissig wie fußgänger
überwege aus jetzt kommt der tag ja du
hast es geschafft dann muss ich aber
irgendwie nochmal machen jetzt werde ich
hier fahrräder aus seite wieder ja das
geschafft das muss ich wieder normal
machen 2 das sind zwei räder
wir schreiben das jahr 2025 soll wohl
nicht seine online-bestellung bis heute
ist allerdings der stadt ist allerdings
auch beenden können eben freundlich
schülern ohne wasser
ich habe da gerade unter meinen
sideboard hier geben das ist wichtig
weiß esch am bau gewesen
ist das jetzt seid ihr in meinem partie
kann im letzten moment noch gekämpft
bester volk immer wieder bin ich auf
jeden fall gefeiert würde ich mich sehr
gerne wahr einen daumen hoch und ich
habe mir ich habe ja wochen zeige dass
viele tibeter gestellt und für mein
schlafzimmer hat jeder der gut gegangen
ist dreimal durch den abend letztendlich
sind wir dennoch fed geschnitten hat
meinen daumen wird den song gar nicht so
lange quatschen das ist schon richtig
spät ich sehe komplett fertig aus und
ich brauchen schlaf wir sehen uns wieder
wenn ich wieder hochladen
[Musik]
[Applaus]